GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELCOME TO OUR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED BMP COMMITTEE HEARING.
THE CHAIR NOTICES THE PRESENCE.
OF.
NUMBER OF THE REPUBLICAN.
SIDE OF THE AISLE AS WELL AS
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. OF WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM AND SO
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE JUST.
OF TO NOTE HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
YOU HAVE SUBS TO MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GOYO WILL BE REPLACING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
WITH THAT BEING SAID WILL BEGIN
WITH THE.
BILLS AND FILE ORDER TODAY.
WE DO HAVE AN EXCEPTION THIS
MORNING DOCTOR REMEMBER HAS
SUBMITTED A FORMAL LETTER.
TO PRESENT FIRST AND SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
WE WILL.
HERE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
DOCTOR RAMBLER AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTEEN A PLEASE JOIN US HERE
UP AT THE PODIUM AND.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR BEING A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL.
AND AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTEEN DOCTOR RAMBLER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN MAKES
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE LICENSING
PROCESS FOR LICENSED MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPISTS. LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS.
THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO INCREASE
CONSISTENCY IN THE LICENSE TYPES
ACROSS THAT THREE PROFESSIONS.
SPECIFICALLY IT SPECIFIES THE
STEPS NEEDED TO RENEW AN EXPIRED
REGISTRATION.
IT EXTENDS THE SAME ACCEPTANCE
OF SUPERVISED EXPERIENCE FOR OUT
OF STATE MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPISTS AND PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELOR APPLICANTS
WHO HAVE BEEN LICENSED IN THEIR
HOME STATE FOR MANY YEARS. TO
OUT OF STATE CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORK APPLICANTS.
IT CORRECTS SOME ERROR IN THE
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORK STATUTE TO
ENSURE CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT
THE STATUTE AND THE LAW FOR THE
BOARD'S OTHER TO LICENSE TYPES.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
STEVE SAGARIN AS WELL AS
ROSEANNE HOMES LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST FOR THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
I GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND LAST
STATED THAT'S BASICALLY GOOD
OVERVIEW OF EVERYTHING SO WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM PLEASE FEEL FREE
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
THE UP THE BITUMINOUS PLEASE
WHATEVER READY GVA HEIRS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN. I THINK
YOU GOING DOCTOR ARAMBULA I JUST
WANTED TO VERIFY IT'S NOT
CHANGING A FOR THE LCSW WE DON'T
BEGIN THE COLLECTION OF OUR
HOURS TILL POST MASTER'S DEGREE.
THE OTHER TWO.
DEGREES ALLOW PEOPLE TO BEGIN
COLLECTING THEIR CLINICAL HOURS
PRE GRADUATION FOR A MASTER'S
DEGREE WHICH IS WHY WE THINK ARE
ARE.
I LICENSES.
THAT WAS SO A COULD YOU RESPOND
TO THAT OUR YOU'RE NOT LOWERING
THE STANDARDS FOR THE LCSW YOU
ARE JUST CREATING SOME.
EQUITIES ACROSS
AFTER THE LICENSE HAS BEEN
ISSUED.
THAT IS CORRECT WERE NOT WERE
NOT ALLOWING THREE DEGREE HOURS
FORFOR LCSW APPLICANTS WERE
JUST.
MAKING SOME CHANGES FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING IN OUT OF STATE
THAT HAVE A SOCIAL WORK LICENSE
OUT OF STATE.
.
THE A THREE THOUSAND THAT IF
EVEN LICENSE MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS WERE ACCEPTING THOSE HOURS
WITHOUT MAKING THEM GO BACK AND
EARN IT OUR.
AND AND WE HAVE WE SAID WE HAVE
SOME ARTICULATION BETWEEN THE
LICENSE UP IN FROM OTHER STATES
AS WELL AND AND THEIR
REQUIREMENTS FOR SUPERVISION OF
OURS.
DO YOU MEAN THAT.
.
I MEAN FOR THE CLINICAL LICENSE
HOW MANY HOURS CAN BE USED WITH
IT UNDER GROUP TO PROVISION HOW
MANY UNDER INDIVIDUAL
SUPERVISION.
SO THEY'RE REQUIRED TO HAVE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED HOURS TOTAL I
BELIEVE IT'S SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS.
FOR.
A CLINICAL AND I THINK THERE'S
A THERE'S NO LIMIT AND IT'S
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED CLINICAL HOURS
IT CAN BE WHATEVER RAPIST THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED TOTAL HOURS THAT ONE
MUST UNDERSTOOD FROM CATEGORIES
THAT YOU CAN COLLECT THE DATA.
YOU HOURS UNDER THE CATEGORY SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF THE OTHER
STATES HOW THE SAME CATEGORIES
THEM WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING AT
LICENSURE AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEBTS.
IT VARIES.
OCC ACROSS STATES BUT A PLAN
WILL MAJORITY OF STATES REQUIRE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED HOURS.
SOME OF THEM SOME OF THEM HAVE
IT IN DIFFERENT WHAT YOU CALL
BUT GETS.
.
BUT.
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE STANDARDS
IT'S ALL VERY SIMILAR TO
CALIFORNIA THERE'S JUST SOME
SOME DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF.
WHAT THEY CALL IT OR?
WHAT THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
ARE BUT I CAN LOOK INTO IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND AND IT'S
MORE INFORMATION IF YOU'D LIKE?
THAT I I WOULD LIKE THAT OKAY.
AND IT ALL AND ALSO THAN OTHER
STATES ALSO DON'T ALLOW. THE
COLLECTION OF LICENSURE HOURS
PRE MASTER'S DEGREE AND OTHER
STATES ARE ALSO OFFER CLINICAL
LICENSE FOR BASHERS LEVEL WE'RE
NOT TALK ABOUT THAT AT THIS TIME
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT OR NOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEN NOT DOCTOR ARAMBULA WOULD
YOU
TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
ALSO ENJOYS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION INTERESTS
RECOMMENDATION AS I.
WE CURRENTLY ARE MISSING ABOUT
ONE ADDITIONAL MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE WILL
ADDRESS THAT AT THE PROPER TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
WELL NOW MOVE ON BACK TO FILE
ORDER AND THAT IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. THIS IS A BE
SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
NINE TWO ONE A MEASURE TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THE BENEFITS OF PRE
EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS. KNOWN AS
PREP
AND POST EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS
PET.
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS AND I'D
LIKE TO SAY WERE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL IS JOINT AUTHORED
WITH ASSEMBLYMAN MIKE GIPSON.
AND COOPER WITH SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER.
PREP IS A HIV AIDS SPECIFIC
PREVENTIVE MEDICATION MEN FOR
DAILY USE
DESPITE PREP SUCCESS IN REDUCING
HIV AIDS INFECTION. BY MORE THAN
NINETY PERCENT HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS ARE RELUCTANT TO
PRESCRIBE PREP BECAUSE THEY
LACKED SUFFICIENT KNOWLEDGE FELT
DISCOMFORT OR STIGMA. RELATIVE
TO DISCUSSING OR TREATMENT
TREATING PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS OR THEY LACK
EXPERIENCE.
IN PRESCRIBING PREP.
ADDITIONALLY THE USE OF PEP
WHICH MUST BE ADMINISTERED
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF
EXPOSURE.
BRITAIN IS WIDELY UNDER UTILIZED
EVEN THOUGH PROVIDERS KNOW OF
PAM.
THEY LACK TRAINING IN
PRESCRIBING AND COUNSELING.
AS A RESULT THESE LIFESAVING
TREATMENTS ARE NOT UTILIZED.
TO BRING AWARENESS TO PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY ONE WOULD REQUIRE THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
OF CALIFORNIA TO CONSIDER
COURSES IN PREP AND PET
MEDICATION MAINTENANCE AND
COUNSELING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER CONTINUING EDUCATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE AMANDA
WALLNER.
WHO WAS DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA A
LGBT HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK?
I THINK I GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
AMANDA WALLER AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THAT CALIFORNIA LGBT HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK WERE
A COALITION OF OVER SIXTY LGBT
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WHO ARE WORKING AYE
TO ACHIEVE LGBT HEALTH EQUITY?
AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE.
WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
HIV.
THIRD SINGLE TABLET TABLET
REGIMENS TREATMENT IS PREVENTION
AYE PREP AND PAP.
THE GOAL OF ENDING AIDS IS IS A
REAL POSSIBILITY.
IN MY LIFETIME.
I.
BUT IN ORDER TO DO SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS.
THE AMAZING TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION METHODS THAT HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISHED OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
PLANT IS NINETY NINE PERCENT
EFFECTIVE AT PREVENTING.
HIV.
AND HAVE.
SEPARATE DRUG ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND THE STATE'S PART NAVIGATORS
HAVE MADE IT EASIER FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AT A HIGH
RISK OF HIV TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THOSE DRUGS HOWEVER WE STILL SEE
MUCH LOWER UPTAKE OF PREP THAN
WE WOULD EXPECT AND A BIG PART
OF THE REASON FOR. THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
I'M BY PROVIDERS
I'VE HEARD COUNTLESS STORIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA OF ON
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD TO GO IN AND
EDUCATE THEIR OWN PROVIDERS
ABOUT WHAT PREP IS.
YOU KNOW WHY THEY NEED IT WHY
THEY'RE A GOOD CANDIDATE FOR IT.
AND IN ORDER TO GET TO THE
LEVELS OF PREP USE THAT WE NEED
TO TO REALIZE THE GOAL OF ENDING
AIDS IN THIS GENERATION.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOCTORS HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE TO BE
ABLE TO PRESCRIBE PREP
COMFORTABLY THAT THEY CAN
IDENTIFY WHO'S A GOOD CANDIDATE.
TO TAKE PROPER WHO'S AT HIGH
RISK.
FOR AYE FOR GETTING HIV IN THAT
THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
PRESCRIBING THAT NOT ONLY WHEN
IT'S.
EXPLICITLY REQUESTED BY A
PATIENT I'M WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
PLEASED TODAY TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU.
MISTER CLEARY STILL THERE.
.
THE BILL HAS.
BABY MOVE YOU SECOND HOUR WE'RE
STILL OPERATING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
AT THIS POINT ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
IF SO PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
BY THE MICROPHONE AND NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE. THANK YOU KNOW SUCH
SHORT KELLY HAD SCIENCES PLEASE
TO BE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIR ONLY THINK THE AUTHOR FOR.
LA ONE BRING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I CHAIR THE INFECTIOUS DISEASE
COMMITTEE.
BUT SELECT COMMITTEE AND HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTHOR ALL AROUND THIS BILL
PREPPING PAT. ON SU GOAT AT THIS
IS HELPING US MOVE GETTING OUT
CLOSER TO ZERO NEW INFECTION
CASES AND DEATH AND STIGMAS.
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH LIVING
WITH HIV AND AIDS AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO COMMUNITY A RULE
COMMUNITIES ARE EXPRESSLY
IMPACTED BY THE LACK OF ACCESS
TO SERVICES.
THAT HAVING DISPROPORTIONATE
HIGH.
NEW INFECTIOUS RATES AND SO
WITH THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK IT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE AUTHOR AND HER
ATTEMPTS TO UP WIND.
GETTING AS CLOSE TO ZERO IN
CALIFORNIA'S OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF IT WILL
TAKE A BREAK TO TAKE A QUICK
LOCAL COUNTY CIRCUIT BECAUSE OF.
LOW I'M HERE. BROKE.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
GIPSON.
HERE.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MAYES.
STEINORTH.
AND TING.
WHICH VERY MUCH WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THIS BEEN UP.
A MOTION AND A SECOND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON WHICH YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S SO CRITICAL WE HAVE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
AN UNDERSTANDING OF THESE
TREATMENTS YOU KNOW AS FOLKS GO
IN AS WE KNOW. KNOWING YOUR
STATUS IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
AND IF YOU HAVE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE EITHER NOT PREPARED OR FEEL
THE STIGMA WHEN DEALING WITH YOU
KNOW THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT THE PATIENT
AND ACTUALLY?
THAT MEETING THE GOALS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR FOR HIV AIDS
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I ALSO
WANT TO COMMEND AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BALK
AND YOU'RE GONNA CHAMPION ON
THESE ISSUES.
PARTICULARLY AFFECTING MEMBERS
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND WE
KNOW THAT THESE HEALTH ISSUES
ARE NONPARTISAN ISSUES AND SO
AGAIN APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THIS ISSUE. OF THIS IS DOES
ENJOY AYE RECOMMENDATION
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE MOTION
IS DO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE. BRO.
I ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN.
EXCEPT.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MAYES.
GLORIA.
STEINORTH.
TING.
YOU VERY MUCH A SUMMER WALDRON
STILL NEED ADDITIONAL VOTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
BUT NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM.
NUMBER FIVE.
THAT IS AB TWENTY THREE HUNDRED.
A SIMILAR MAIENSCHEIN.
PLEASE JOIN US.
AND FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY WELCOME
WATCH A MEAN MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I BEFORE I BEGIN I WILL
ACCEPT BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AND I AND I LIKE TO
TAKE THIS THANK THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY THREE HUNDRED WOULD
AUTHORIZE WOULD AUTHORIZE
VETERINARIANS TO FULFILL ALL OR
PART OF THEIR SELF STUDY.
CONTINUING EDUCATION COURSEWORK
ASSOCIATED WITH PRO BONO SPAY
AND NEUTER SERVICES
VOLUNTARY SPAY NEUTER NEUTER
SERVICES FOR CATS AND DOGS HAS
CONSISTENTLY BEEN PROVEN. AS AN
EFFECTIVE METHOD IN REDUCING
SHELTER AND TAKE A AND
EUTHANASIA RATES SOME
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED LAWS
REQUIRING MANDATORY ALTERATION
OF DOGS AND CATS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY COST AS A PRIMARY
BARRIER. TO SPAY AND NEUTER
SURGERY IN MANY COMMUNITIES.
A TWO THOUSAND NINE PEER
REVIEWED STUDY BY THE JOURNAL OF
AMERICAN VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. FOUND THAT SPAY
NEUTER RATES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER FOR ANIMALS LIVING AN
HOUSEHOLDS EARNING THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
LESS ANNUALLY.
FOR THESE LOWER INCOME PET
OWNERS HIGH COSTS WERE THE MOST
COMMONLY CITED REASON
FOR NOT ALL TRADING NOT ALTERING
THEIR ANIMALS.
THE UNATTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THESE LAWS.
IS THE RIGHT WING WHICH MEANT
OF A BELOVED FAMILY PET TO A
LOCAL SHELTER. DUE TO THE HIGH
COST WHICH AND EAT WHICH CAN
EASILY GO INTO THE HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS.
MATT LAUER VETERINARIANS TO
OBTAIN CONTINUING EDUCATION
CREDIT.
THAT WIL LIKELY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF THAT'S WILLING TO
PROVIDE SUCH SERVICES BOTH NEW
YORK AND NEW JERSEY HAVE SEATS
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED SIMILAR
PROGRAMS.
I AND THEY HAVE WORKED VERY WELL
AB TWENTY THREE HUNDRED WOULD
ALLOW THAT'S TO COMPLETE THEIR
MANDATORY SELF STUDY COURSE WORK
BY VOLUNTEERING WITHIN LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
AND PROVIDING CRUCIAL SURGERIES
I WILL ASSESS WHAT SHELTER
OVERCROWDING WITH ME TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OF AB TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED.
SUSAN RAGS THE SENIOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR A SPCA.
HI GOOD MORNING SUSAN RATES OF
THE SPCA ON THIS BILL A CONCEPT
REALLY ARISES OUT OF OUR
EXPERIENCE IN LA COUNTY WHERE
WE'VE GOT A MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
I'M INVESTMENT IN THE COMMUNITY
THERE WAS A VERY HIGH. SHELTER
INTAKE ANIMAL SHELTER INTAKE
AND%
EUTHANASIA RATE AND LA COUNTY
AND WHAT.
WE DID WAS WE ACTUALLY PLACE
TEAMS ON THE GROUND AT SOME OF
THE.
SOLDIERS WITH THE LOCK HIGHEST
INTAKE IN EUTHANASIA RATES
AND THOSE HAPPEN TO BE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND WHAT WE
FOUND WHEN WE. INTERVENED IN
PEOPLE COMING TO THE SHELTER TO.
RELINQUISH THEIR PAD WE ASK
THEM YOU KNOW WHY ARE YOU DOING
THIS IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO HELP KEEP YOU TOGETHER WITH
YOUR PATH.
AND IT TURNS OUT ONE OF THE MOST
FREQUENTLY CITED REASONS WAS AND
THAT PARTICULAR CASE A MANDATORY
SPAY NEUTER LAW THERE AND THE
FOLKS JUST REALLY DID NOT HAVE
THE MEANS TO.
TIP TIP I'D DO THE SURGERY NOT
TO MENTION JUST HAVING ACCESS TO
THE SURGERY IN THEIR COMMUNITY
IT'S.
YA WELL DOCUMENTED THAT IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THERE IT
REALLY IS A DEARTH OF VETERINARY
SERVICES GENERALLY. BUT THEN
WHEN YOU ADD THE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF HAVING A
MANDATORY LAW IN THOSE
PARTICULAR CASE SAYS YOU THE GAP
REALLY REALLY GROWS AND SO
THERE'S REALLY LITTLE TO NO
ACCESS. SO THIS IS THE
EXPERIENCE LA COUNTY BUT REALLY
NATIONALLY WE SEE THE SAME
THING.
THE STATISTICS SHOW EIGHTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF PETS
NATIONALLY ARE.
SPAYED NEUTERED BUT IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
THAT.
STATISTIC FALL TO NINE PERCENT
SO I'M WE SEE THIS IN
OPPORTUNITY GIVEN ON THE SUCCESS
OF THAT NEW JERSEY AND YOUR
CLAWS.
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT MARY'S AND
THAT THAT'S TO GET OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO REALLY DO SOMETHING
GOOD FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING BUT
JUST. DON'T HAVE ACCESS AND
THERE'S A FINANCIAL BARRIER
THERE THIS CAN REALLY HELP.
LIMON PHILLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA CAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE NOW IN THE OFFICIAL
TWEENER POSITION. OF WATCH WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
ON PAGE THREE ONE I THINK THE
pBRINGS UP SOME GOOD POINTS THAT
WE HAD RAISED AND.
.
WITHOUT THE EXCELLENT WORK OF
MISTER FRENCH AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'D BE HERE TODAY HE.
OUT COALESCED US WITHIN ABOUT A
FORTY EIGHT HOUR PERIOD WITH
SOME EXCELLENT DISCUSSIONS IT
REALLY ONE A LONG WAY TO BRING
US TO THIS MODEST COMPROMISE
THIS MORNING. I REALLY WANT TO
THANK MISTER CHAIR FOR MEETING
WITH US LAST WEEK FOR MR
MAIENSCHEIN AND ALL GOT HIS
STAFF IN OF COURSE SUSAN RIGS
FOR THE COURTESIES EXTENDED TO
US SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SEE.
SEEING NONE THREE MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEE KNOW QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR COULD BE MEMBERS MISMATCH
I'M WHICH YOU WISH TO CLOSE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN REYES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
A SEMI MAJOR EFFORT ALSO WORKING
AND DILIGENTLY WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS COMMITTEE
AS WELL THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION CAN BE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED A MAN I HAD
WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I BROKE.
ROBERT BROWN NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLEW.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GREAT GRAYSON I HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MAYES.
MAYES I GLORIA.
STEINORTH.
TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU STILL LEAVE THE
ROLE FOR OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL.
BOOKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL NOW.
LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS I
SEE NONE IN THE AUDIENCE BUT I
DO SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN A
FOR A FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN MY MIGHT
YOU BE READY TO PERCENT AT THIS
TIME.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THIS IS CAN FILE AND REMEMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWO FOUR FIVE SEVEN IS A
VERY VERY SIMPLE BILL IT SIMPLY
CHANGES THE NAME OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF KODIAK
TRICK.
OF MEDICINE TO THE PODIA TRACK
OF MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE. BOARD
OF KODIAK TRICK OF MEDICINE WAS
REMOVED FROM THE JURISDICTION OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD CALIFORNIA AND
TURNED INTO AN INDEPENDENT BOARD
AT THIS CHANGE MADE IT THE THIRD
MEDICAL BOARD IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
THE GO FOR ITS CURRENT TITLE
DOES NOT REFLECT ITS NEW
RESPONSIBILITY. HAD TO FOUR FIVE
SEVEN WOULD MAKE THE BOARD.
I WOULD PROVIDE THE BOARD WITH
THE TITLE THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER MEDICAL INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL BOARDS.
SEC. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH
INSIST HE CAN SUPPORT HERE AT
THE PORT.
BRIAN IS ON THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER CALIFORNIA BORDER PUT
YET MEDICINE.
AND WE'RE SPONSORING THE BILL
AND WE SUPPORT AND WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL. THAT.
THIS COMPONENT OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE.
HAS IT WILL BE IDENTIFIED AS AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL BOARD. FOR
CLEAR CONSUMER UNDERSTANDING
THANK YOU.
WHEN SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUT YAK MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM KEY MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
TINO QUESTION BECOMES A BUT
THERE WAS A MOTION IT WAS OUR
SECOND AS WELL YES.
I THINK I DID YOU KNOW THAT
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY.
SOMEONE IRWIN WHICH YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
TECH CLASS RIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN I'VE
APPRECIATE OF YOUR COME INTO
THIS ISSUE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL.
POLICY DISCUSSIONS WITH RESPECT
TO SUNSET REVIEW A COMING UP IN
TWENTY TONY CA TWENTY TWENTY AND
SO OF THIS DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW AYE
ROW. ROW AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER
SPEAKER I BLOOM.
JILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
I IRWIN AYE MAYES.
MAYES I GLORIA.
STEINORTH TING.
BUT VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WERE AND
WILL LEAVE THE WILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR.
THAT IS AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMING
HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CABRERO. PLEASE
PRESENT WHEN EVERYBODY WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE. WHICH
WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES BY
PROVIDING AN INCENTIVE FOR
CURRENTLY LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO GAIN MEDICAL
TRAINING USING EXISTING TRAINING
PROGRAMS WE START OFF BY SAYING
I AM PLEASED TO ACCEPT. THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WHICH
FURTHER EXPAND ACCESS TO THE
LOAN PROGRAM BUT I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
ISSUES WITH THAT. PA PROGRAM FEE
CHARGE IN WHICH I SPOKE TO THE
CHAIR ABOUT AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
THERE'S A RESOLUTION FOR THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A SHORTAGE
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WHO CAN PROVIDE ACCESS TO
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES.
THERE SIMPLY AREN'T ENOUGH
GRADUATING PSYCHIATRIST TO MEET
CURRENT DEMAND ONE IN FOUR
PSYCHIATRISTS POSITION IN COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM STATEWIDE
OUR BACON AT ANY ONE TIME.
SOME ESTIMATES INDICATE THAT
DURING ANY ONE YEAR TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION WILL BENEFIT FROM
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND FIFTY
PERCENT OF OUR POPULATION OVER
THEIR LIFETIME WILL REQUIRE THE
SERVICES. IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
ADDRESS THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
NEEDS OF OUR CITIZENS PARTICULAR
HER PARTICULARLY AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND I THINK. I'M SOME OF
THE INCIDENTS THE VIOLENCE
INCIDENTS THAT HAVE OCCURRED
RECENTLY REALLY UNDERSCORED THE
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND THE AVAILABILITY OF THOSE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
CRISIS.
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE AMEND
STATUTES FOR EXISTING SAY
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE MENTAL
HEALTH LOAN ASSUMPTION PROGRAM
TO ALLOW DUAL STATUS TRAINEES.
MEETING CERTAIN CRITERIA TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT IF THEY'RE WILLING TO
WORK AND UNDERSERVED RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
INCREASING OPPORTUNITY FOR
LICENSE.
PSYCHOTHERAPIST TO GAIN DUAL
LICENSURE AS PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANTS OR PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONERS WILL
HELP.
UP FINE AND ATTRACT THEM TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES GROWING
THE PSYCHIATRIC WARD WORKFORCE
WILL EXPAND THE SERVICES.
TWO PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESSES WHICH WILL LEAD TO
REDUCE WAIT TIMES FOR
APPOINTMENTS AND MARK MOST INPUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY. EARLIER
EVALUATION AND TREATMENT.
TO TAKE STEP A STEP TOWARD
CLOSING THE GAP IN ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES I ASK FOR
YOUR I BOW TO SUPPORT THIS LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM EXPANSION.
WITH ME TODAY IS RHONDA HAGER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
MEG.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
I AM RENTAL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS ARE ATTESTED MEANS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
ON THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE AS A WAY TO GET TO THOSE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
STATE FEDERALLY. IDENTIFIED
AREAS WHERE THERE IS.
EITHER NO OR VERY.
VERY LITTLE MALE HEALTH SERVICE.
IS THIS BILL IS AN ATTEMPT TO
TAKE THE NEXT STEP TOWARDS
PROVIDING AN INTEGRATED TEAM
BASED CONCEPT AND CARE. IT'S
MORE COMPREHENSIVE AND IN ITS
APPROACH IT IMPROVE ACCESS TO
CARE USES EXISTING RESOURCES AND
IT HAS AT NO ADDITIONAL COST TO
THE STATE WE COMMEND THIS TO
YOUR. TO YOUR VOTES HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT HOPEFULLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TEST MY
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURSTYN MADDEN
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
MERIT BECAUSE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
XENA WITNESSES OPPOSITION A
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU THAT AND JUST ENDED A
COMMENT JUST A THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS BILL I MEAN I
THINK MOM THOSE OF US WHO
REPRESENT PARTS OF RURAL
CALIFORNIA KNOW THAT. MORE
PEOPLE WE HAVE TO DO MORE WITH
LESS AND SO GETTING PEOPLE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF EXPERTISE
AND LICENSURE PRINT CAN ONLY
HELP AND AS WE ALSO KNOW IN
SOME.
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE OFTEN FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE SEEKING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SO IT FIRST
PRESENTS ITSELF AND MORE
PHYSICAL CEMENTITE WAY SO IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE SOMEBODY UP
SOMETHING ELSE. AND WHILE YOU'RE
THERE THERE'S MORE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IT'S THAT THAT THAT CAN
ONLY HELP AND AND YOU'RE RIGHT
THE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND THEN MAKE SURE IT
GETS PAID FOR.
TO BE ABLE FOR GIVE THAT IS OF A
HUGE STEP FORWARD. OF FOR
OBSERVING RURAL CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WHICH.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COMING OUT WHICH
YOU WISH TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELL I CAN TELL YOU THAT
DID LONGER REPAYMENT PROGRAM HAS
MADE A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN
IN MY DISTRICT.
FOR FOR DOCTORS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ATTRACT
DOCTORS TO COME TO OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF THIS REPAYMENT
PROGRAM IN THE STATE ONCE THEY
GET THERE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU THAT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST. CONCERNS IT'S BEEN
RAISED TO ME RECENTLY IS ON
STUDENTS THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
IT LACK OF THOSE KINDS OF
SERVICES ONS SCHOOL SITES BUT.
BASICALLY ANYWHERE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE CONCERNED THAT IF THEY
THEY.
SEE SOMETHING ARE THEY ARE THEY
FEEL SOMETHING THAT THERE'S NO
ONE THAT CAN GO TO ANY AND THE
MORE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT
SERVICES. UP LOCALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITY THE BETTER WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT ARE
REALLY PLAGUE US SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
OUR CONVERSATION WHEN WE HAD OUR
ONE ON ONE
AND YOU DEMONSTRATED A
SIGNIFICANT ON.
A SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE GIVEN
YOUR PREVIOUS CAPACITY IN
ADMINISTRATION AND I APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH YOU
CAN ACHIEVE. PRICKLY AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD OF THIS DOES
ENJOY A DEEP PASS RECOMMENDATION
INDENTURES I RECOMMENDATION. UP
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOST IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HEALTH LOW
AYE LOWAYE BRO. BRO AYE
ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE HE BLOOM. CHIU
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN AYE
MAYES. MAYES AYE GLORIA.
STEINORTH TING.
A THAT HAS A RECORD NUMBER OF
VOTES REGULATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS A
VERY FAMILIAR THANK YOU.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX.
THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO.
I ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO PLEASE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO WHICH WILL SET
SAFE TEMPERATURE STANDARDS FOR
THE MOBILE.
TRANSPORTATION OF DOGS AND CATS.
CURRENTLY OF CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS A PERSON FROM LEAVING
AN ANIMAL IN AN UNATTENDED MORE
TO MOTOR VEHICLE UNDER
CONDITIONS THAT ENDANGER THE
ANIMAL'S HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
HOWEVER THERE IS NO LAW
REQUIRING SEE TEMPERATURE
CONTROL DURING THE
TRANSPORTATION OF THESE ANIMALS.
MY BILL AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO ADDRESSES IT THIS ISSUE BY
ESTABLISHING NEW SAFE
TEMPERATURE STANDARDS FOR THE
MOBILE TRANSPORTATION OF DOGS
AND CATS TO ENSURE THEIR
PROTECTION. FROM TEMPERATURE
RELATED INJURIES OR DEATH.
STUDIES SHOW THAT ANIMALS CAN
SINCE WELL SINCE I'VE GOT A MOVE
IN A SECOND AYE WE CAN CONTINUE.
I KNOW WHEN TO BE QUIET THANK
YOU.
I I HAVE YOUR WITH ME TO DO IN
KOSOVO IS.
HELPING WITH ABOUT.
CAN I SAY SOMETHING. I YOU I
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
JUDY MAN CREW SO AND I AM THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX I
WORKED WITH SENATOR LIZ FIGUEROA
ON S. B. EIGHTEEN NO SIX WHICH
BECAME LAW FIVE NINETY SEVEN DOT
SEVEN. ANIMALS IN UNINTENDED
VEHICLES AND TODAY I GET TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER HER BLANCA
RUBIO THAT WE ARE HONORED TO BE.
SPONSORING THIS BILL TO FURTHER
WHAT WE STARTED.
BACK WITH A SENATOR FIGUEROA
AND EXTEND THE REGULATIONS AND
HELPING DOGS AND CATS
OF FROM DYING IN HOT VEHICLES IS
WHAT IT BOILS DOWN TO. SO SINCE
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT'S ALL I'M GONNA SAY IS WELL
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
IT'S YOU KNOW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND ARE ANY MEMBERS OF.
NUMBERS AS PART.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOW AND HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
PUPPY SPOT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
ABOUT A POSITION PARK MARKANDEYA
WITH CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION YET ON THE BILL
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT SOME IMPACTS.
POTENTIALLY ON BREEDERS OF
SPORTING DOGS
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS AND APPRECIATE HER
WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT THANK
YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOT ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COUNTY MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS ARE COMING UP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THINKING I WAS
JUST CURIOUS IN THIS IS.
I WASN'T ON THE POLICY COMMITTEE
FOR THIS BUT WHAT ABOUT LIKE
SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES LIKE
LIKE ON A STOCK AND WE HAVE A
MUCH HIGHER KILL RATE THEM WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE BECAUSE WE HAVE A
VERY HIGH DEGREE OF. POVERTY
WHICH MEANS
A LOT OF DOGS OUT ABOUT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE COMMITTEES
AT THAT ARE BARELY STRUGGLING TO
KEEP THEIR THEIR SHELTERS GOINGS
WAS WELL THEY CAN IN THE ADDED
COSTS AND OF UPDATING ALL OF THE
THE FLEET OF VEHICLES AS WELL.
SO RIGHT NOW YOUR SHELTER AND
OTHERS ALREADY HAVE VEHICLES
MOST OF THEM ARE VERY OLD
ANTIQUATED. AND.
WITH THE RISING TEMPERATURES IN
THE SUMMER.
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT
THAT THESE ANIMALS ARE PUT IN A
SITUATION
SO WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM ANY
CITIES OR COUNTIES ARE ANIMAL
CONTROL AGAINST THIS. AMERICA
FACT THEY ARE SUPPORT OF AND
WORKING WITH US TO FLESH OUT THE
A LANGUAGE SO THEY WANT IT THEY
DON'T WANT TO OPEN THESE
VEHICLES AND HAVE DEAD ANIMALS
THAT THEY'RE PULLING OUT. AND IT
IS WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
FORTUNATELY SO.
I HAVE MANY FOLKS IN STOCKTON
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH FOR
OVER TEN YEARS AND I WILL
PERSONALLY REACH OUT TO THEM AND
GET THEM ON OUR COALITION TEAM.
THANK YOU KNOW. THE DID ARMS I
DO NOT QUESTION THE DESIRE
EVERYBODY WELL I UNDERSTAND THE
COST I DO THAT THAT'S ABOUT
THAT'S MY QUESTION IS THERE'S IS
THERE ARE THERE PROVISIONS OR L.
AND OR IS THERE. A TIMELINE IN
WHICH FACILITIES MUST BE UP TO
TO COAT WE CAN CERTAINLY FLESH
THAT OUT IT WE HAVEN'T.
GONE THROUGH.
THANK YOU FOR RAISING THAT
QUESTION BUT WE HAVEN'T LOOKED
AT THAT AND I'M I'M WILLING TO
SIT DOWN WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN COME UP
WITH A PROGRAM. AND HOPEFULLY
FIND SOME FUNDING FOR I'VE TO
SUPPORT BE DISEASE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERN AND ON LA COUNTY
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE AND AND
IT'S IT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT WE
HAVE THAT THE THE GOOD AREAS IN
THE BAD AREAS IN THERE UNDER THE
SAME.
THEY HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM AS
AS AS THE RURAL COMMUNITIES WAIT
BUT I'M LIKE I SAID I WILL.
DEFICIT DOWN AND SEE IF WE CAN
FIND SOME FUNDING OUGHT TO
SUPPORT THOSE THOSE COMMUNITIES
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLYMAN REVIEW IF YOU WISH
TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU AGAIN I
WOULD I AM COMMITTED TO SEND
BALLOTS STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS. A FLESHED OUT
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S AYE
FEASIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND.
ONE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT AND WORKING WITH
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL THIS
DOES ENJOY A CAN PASS
RECOGNITION THE CHAIRS WRECK. AS
AN AYE THAT THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION IS THE PAST LAP AYE LOW
AYE BRO.
BROWN NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BIGGER AYE BLOOM.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE STEINORTH
TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY OR
REVIEW WILL LEAVE THEIR ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE TO MORE ITEMS WHO.
WITH. ONE OF THE AUTHORS
CURRENTLY PRESENTING IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
AND SO I WILL GO ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS AG ARE
TWENTY SEVEN BY MYSELF I'M GONNA
PASSED THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR.
VICE CHAIR.
WELL NOW TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AJ ARE TWENTY SEVEN BY
CHAIR LOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPEARANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR VICE CHAIR THIS IS OUR HR
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS A TECH
DIRECT RESPONSE FROM. ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
JEFF SESSIONS AND HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE WOULD
RESCIND EXISTING POLICY THAT
DISCOURAGE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
IN MOST CASES FROM PROSECUTING
CANNABIS AND STATES.
THAT HAVE BE LEGALIZED
THAT HAVE LEGALIZED SOME OF THIS
DRUG AT THIS AGE YOU ARE TWENTY
SEVEN CALLS ON THEIR ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO RESPECT OUR
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS LAWS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE AS YOU KNOW IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN OVER FIFTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS
FOR ADULTS TWENTY ONE AND OVER.
THIS IS A AND.
KEY STATEMENTS AND SUPPORTING OF
THE CONTENTS IN THE WILL OF THE%
PEOPLE AND IT IS OUR INTENT TO
ALSO ADD ADDITIONAL COAUTHORS ON
BOTH. SIDES OF THE AISLE
INCLUDING.
MORE SO AUTHORS PREVIOUSLY AND I
KNOW THAT SOME OTHER. MEMBERS WE
HAD WHICH TO PRESENT AS WELL BUT
THERE FROM THE START THE
COMMITTEES THAT WITH RESPECT I
ASK ARRIVAL.
CHAIR WILL HAVE WELL WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
IN MELANIE CUEVAS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANDIDATES
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS JASON
BRYANT AFTER CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
SOME NUMBER WOULD LIKE TO
BECOME.
THANK YOU MR PEROT.
MISTER AND MEMBERS SO.
JUST JUST PRECUT BRIEF BRIEF
COMMENTS YOU DON'T MIND.
.
I GOT INVOLVED IN CANNABIS
POLICY.
BECAUSE OF THE INCREDIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE BEING DONE
IN MY DISTRICT.
THE LIST LEGISLATIVE BODIES WERE
HARD OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
INDUSTRY THAT CREATES A PATHWAY
TO COMPLIANCE FOR BUSINESS
OWNERS. THAT WANT TO DO THE
THINGS IN THE RIGHT WAY.
THEY RETURN WE STRIVE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS LEGAL INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WILL UNDERCUT
THE BLACK MARKET. AND RUN THESE
BAD ACTORS OUT OF BUSINESS.
PRESS THE BIGGEST INCENTIVE
CALIFORNIA.
CANNOT PROMISE CANNABIS
BUSINESS OWNERS IN EXCHANGE FOR
PAYING TAXES LICENSE FEES COMPLY
WITH SOME OF THE STRICTEST
PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS IN THE
WORLD. IS THE PROMISE OF
LEGITIMACY IN THE EYES OF THE
LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
THREATENING TO TREAT A
LEGITIMATE TAX PAYING BUSINESS
OWNERS NO DIFFERENTLY THAN
CARTEL TRESPASS GROWERS.
THIS AND CERTAINLY UNDERMINES
EVERYTHING THIS LEGISLATURE IN
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA SET IN
MOTION. ONLY SERVES TO
PERPETUATE THE BLACK MARKET
OPERATORS.
MEANWHILE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WE'RE FIGHTING A VERY REAL
OPIATE CRISIS THAT IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF REAL
RESOURCES.
AND A PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS ARE
PRESCRIBED EVERY YEAR TO KILL
EVERY CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN
TWICE.
RESULTS HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING.
THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH PERIOD
BETWEEN JULY FIFTEENTH.
TO THAT EXTENT CHAU AYE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN INTO AYE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
NINE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR
LIVES AS A RESULT OF DRUG
OVERDOSES.
TRENT PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY
OPIOIDS INCLUDING HEROIN AND FAT
NO.
PLEASE JOIN CHAIRMAN IN A LOW
AND I AND ASKING ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS TO FOCUS
HIS SIGHTS ON THE TRUE DRUG
CRISIS IN AMERICA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
FOR BRING THE RESOLUTION FORWARD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE.
YOU VERY MUCH INSULIN THOUGHT WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE TO HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING ABOUT TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY MEMBERS
WISHING SPEAK.
SEEING NONE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER GIBSON OF. RESOLUTION
BE IN NEED OF A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER GLORIA.
MISTER CHAIR. I CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE OF FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO THIS ISSUE. AND ALSO WANTED
TO RECOGNIZE THE NOTION THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY IN THE
SUMMER CUNNINGHAM HAVE I MADE
THE COMMAND SIMPLY TO JOIN. AS A
CO AUTHORS OF THIS MEASURE AS
WELL IN ADDITION TO A NUMBER OF
OTHER.
AUTHORS ADDS TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
CHAIR.
WE HAVE A MOTION MEMBERS GIPSON
SECOND A MUSCULAR CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION IS TO BE ADOPTED LOW.
I LOW AYE BRO.
BROUGH NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MAYES.
MAYES I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE STEINORTH TING.
OTHER A VOTES ON CALL
.
IF YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS AND MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WE HAVE ONE FINAL ITEM.
AND THAT IS
A FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
A. B.. TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY
SOME WOMEN BONTA.
SOME AVON I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
HELPING OTHER COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING HERE
AND ETHICS EXPEDITIOUS MANNER
PLEASE PRESENT WHATEVER IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES MY APOLOGIES FOR THE
DELAY THIS GOT OUT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
A POLICEMAN AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE A
PHARMACY TO PROVIDE PHARMACY
SERVICES TO PATIENTS OF SAFETY
NET CLINICS THROUGH THE USE.
OF AN AUTOMATED DRUG DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
THIS WILL HELP IMPROVE ACCESS TO
THE NEEDED I'M DRUGS AND
MEDICINES IN AND RIGHT NOW UNDER
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW.
THESE ULTIMATE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
ARE LETTER OR FREE CLINICS BUT
MAY ONLY OPERATE UNDER THE
CLINICS LICENSE.
ARE BILL WOULD ALLOW PHARMACIES
TO TAKE ON ALL OF THIS
RESPONSIBILITY AND OUT PATIENT
CLINICS THAT OUR PATIENTS
AT SAFETY NET FACILITIES
ACCURACY THE SAME DEGREE A
PHARMACIST CARE. AND SAID THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT CHANGE YOU THINK
THIS'LL BANG I'M NEEDED
MEDICATIONS AND DRUGS CLOSER TO
PATIENTS. WHO ARE?
NEED THEM AND SEE I THINK IT'S
IMMODEST CHANGE AND A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO HELP IMPROVE
HEALTHCARE IN IN CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO WITNESSES
KEVIN ROOM REPRESENTING I MG ARE
ACTS THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF
TECHNICALITIES ANY ERA READ.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HE'S WHENEVER IT MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER THE COMMITTEES THIS IS A
SMART BILL THAT MANAGES TO USE
RESPONSIBLE TECHNOLOGY AND
RELIABLE OVERSIGHT.
TWO OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS SAFE ACCESS TO
MEDICATION.
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKE
HOLDERS INCLUDING THE PHARMACY
BOARD REPRESENTATION. WITH WHOM
WE HAVE ADDRESSED WE BELIEVE ALL
OF THEIR CONCERNS WILL CONTINUE
TO TALK OF ANY OTHER CONCERN
SHOULD SURFACE.
TODAY WE HAVE KEVIN ROOF I AM
GRX WILL MAKE A BRIEF STATEMENT
IN ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND AND.
I HOPE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR.
ARE BILL.
MY COMPANY CURRENTLY OPERATES.
EIGHTEEN.
PHARMACIES IN SAFETY NET
CLINICS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE MRS MISSION IS
TO BRING PHARMACY SERVICES?
AND SHEET MEDICATIONS TO
PATIENTS.
AT THESE CLINICS AND.
WE THINK THIS.
THIS AUTOMATED PROCESS IS THE
NEXT STEP IN EXPANDING THAT
CARE.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HE YOU KNOW WITNESSES OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MOMENT EGGMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM SURE A.
YOU CAN USUALLY ALL BUT ABOUT
THE THE SAFETY ASPECTS OF THE
HOUSE SO WE HAVE MORE MEDICATION
KEPT CLINICS.
HOW WE KNOW THAT PHARMACIES ARE
BIG AREA NOW OF CONCERN FOR
PEOPLE BREAKING EN AND STEALING
THINGS?
IF AND IF WE'RE GONNA BE MORE
OUTLYING AREAS WOMEN THIS IS
THIS IS THAT THE SERVER. A
POPULATION WITHOUT AS MANY
SERVICES THEN WHAT KIND OF
SAFETY THINGS ARE SET UP TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE THE
MEDICATIONS STAY SAFE UNTIL THEY
GET INTO THE PATIENT.
A WE DID DISCUSS.
SAFETY ISSUES AT LENGTH WITH
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY AND WE
HAVE. TAKEN THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SAFETY ISSUES
THE MACHINE IS A IS A SECURE.
MACHINE IT'S ACCESSIBLE.
BITE BY ONLY BY PATIENTS WITH
THE PROPER IDENTIFICATION AND
THAT INCLUDES THEIR THEIR
PRESCRIPTION NUMBERS AND COAT.
.
THE LOADING OF THE MACHINE IS IS
A COMPLETELY SEPARATE.
PROCESS WHERE THERE'S A
SEPARATE COMPARTMENT.
THAT IS.
SHUT OFF FROM THE REST IN THE
MACHINE.
SO.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS THE.
OR.
AND AND.
THE MACHINE STOCKS ITSELF IT'S
VERY SECURE.
.
AS I SAID WE HAVE DISCUSSED
THIS.
THE SAFETY ISSUES AT LENGTH
WITH THE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
OKAY INTENSO ELEMENT AND THE
DISPENSARIES SILICON BY IT ATM
DISPENSARY.
PEOPLE PUT THEIR INFORMATION AND
THEN THE MEDICATION COMES OUT.
OKAY WITH WITH EVERY STEP OF
THAT PROCESS.
SUPERVISED.
AND INITIATED BY A LICENSED
PHARMACIST YES AND AND THERE
WOULD IS THERE ONLY A THE
ALLOWANCE FOR CERTAIN ARRAY OF
OF FAMILIES OF DRUGS TO BE USED
IN THIS KIND OF. DISPENSING LOUD
AT AT THE PRESENT TIME WE DON'T
INTEND TO USE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES IN THE MACHINES
THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THOSE
SAFETY CONCERNS.
BUT THE MACHINE A IS CAPABLE.
OF OF HANDLING THEM BUT OF THE
FORMULARY WILL BE DETERMINED BY
THE NEEDS
OF THE CLINIC WHERE THE MACHINE
IS LOCATED SO SO EACH DISPENSARY
WILL HAVE ITS OWN.
THE FORMULA IS ONE OKAY. BASED
ON BASED ON WHO THEY'RE TREATED
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BY SURPRISE.
THANK MISTER JUST OF.
A PROCESS QUESTION SO IT WOULD
JUST BE.
S. B. LIKE A.
FOOD VENDING MACHINE WOULD BE
OWNED BY THE CLINIC WOULD WITH A
LICENSED PHARMACIST COME AND IT
OPERATED AS SOME COMMENT WHAT'S
THE PROGNOSIS OF THE.
BUT NONE UNDER THIS PROCESS THE
PHARMACY.
WILL OWN AND OPERATE THE MACHINE
AND BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SAFETY. AND SECURITY OF THE
DRUGS INSIDE.
EVERY.
.
EVERY IT'S THE THE THE PROCESS
FOR THE PATIENT IS THE SAME AS
IF YOU WALK UP TO. A PHARMACY
WINDOW.
ONLY IN THIS CASE YOU'RE WALKING
UP TO A MACHINE THAT ACTUALLY
HAS A A VIDEO SCREEN SO YOU CAN
SEE. THE PHARMACIST IF YOU IF
YOU LIKE.
SO IT'S NOT A COME IN OKAY I'M
IN THE MOOD FOR THIS DRUG TODAY.
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND THE
THEN THE PHARMACY WILL SAY OKAY.
MISTER BREAUX WE HAVE THIS
PRESCRIPTION FOR YOU ARE YOU
READY FOR US TO FILL IT.
AND AND ASSUMING THAT YOU SAY
YES THE THE DRUG POOLS THE
MEDICATION IT'S IT'S STOPPED IN
UNITS OF USE.
WHICH IS A TYPICAL PRESCRIPTION
RUN OF SAY THIRTY PILLS.
IT SHOWS.
THAT CONTAINER TO THE
PHARMACIST.
WHO IDENTIFIES AND SAYS YES
THAT'S THE RIGHT DRUG FOR MR
PEROT?
AND THEN THE PHARMACIST CAUSES
THE MACHINE TO LABEL.
THE THE CONTAINER AND AGAIN.
THE MACHINE SHOWS IT TO THE
PHARMACIST TO WHO CONFIRMS.
THE PHARMACIST OFFERS YOU YOUR
CONSULTATION.
YOU CAN HAVE THAT CONSULTATION
ON AN AUDIO VISUAL CONNECTION OR
IF YOU WANT A SEPARATE CALL.
THAT CERTAINLY AVAILABLE TO YOU.
AND THEN WHEN ALL THAT PROCESS
IS DONE THE PHARMACISTS CHECK
YOUR RECORDS FOR FOR DRUG
INTERACTIONS AND ALL THAT JUST
THE SAME AS IF YOU GO TO A
PHARMACY WINDOW. THE PHARMACIST
A. HITS A BUTTON AND RELEASES A
DRUG TO THE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMES FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CNN.
ASSEMBLY ABOUT HER WHICH YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FEAR CONVERSATION
RESPECT THAT'S FOR MY VOTE.
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S THEM.
AND BY.
SECOND BY VICE CHAIR BROKE
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BONTA APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
COMING TO THIS ISSUE.
IT DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
LOW.
I'VE LOW AYE BRO. BRO I
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN I AM MAYES.
MAYES I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE STEINORTH TING.
GRADUATION YOU BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF.
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO BACK
INTO ORDER FOR ADDITIONAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
I COMMITTEE SECRETARY.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE YEAH I
ENJOYED A DO PASS OF THE MINUTES
TO APPROPRIATIONS BRO. BRO I
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
WHEN I.
THE BILL IS A.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN BY
DOCTOR REGULAR MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
I'VE LOW AYE BRO.
THERE THERE WAS A MOTION FOR
THIS ONE BECAUSE IT WE WERE NOT
A QUORUM.
THERE WAS I THINK IT'S.
IN OTHER LAWYER WANTS TO JUST
LIE UP.
THANK YOU.
WHATEVER OUR BROKE BROUGH AYE.
ARABIA.
I MEAN I.
BAKER.
I BAKER AYE BLUE.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MAYES
MAYES I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE STEINORTH TING.
TING AYE.
CONGRATULATIONS
YOUR BILL IS OUT.
AB TWENTY THREE HUNDRED MOTIONS
DO POSTHUMOUS UP TO.
WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BROWN OF VOTE AROUND THAT.
I AM NOT AYE BAKER.
BIG TWENTY THREE HUNDRED.
BAKER I.
THE BILL ITSELF.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TILL.
THIS IS A DO PASS.
BRO.
BLOOM.
BUT I.
TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT
.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
MOTIONS DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
BLUE.
WHEN I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
TING TING AYE.
THE BILL ALREADY HAS THE
REQUISITE NUMBER OF VOTES.
BUT GO NOW GOING TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT.
AJ ARE TWENTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
BE ADOPTED.
BLOOM.
WHEN I.
TING.
TING AYE ARAMBULA.
BRENDA I.
OKAY
THE GOVERNMENT WILL.
LEAVES THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL FEW MINUTES FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND WILL GO
BACK AND IN ORDER FOR.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE TING.
TING AYE.
SOME TO NINETY ONE GLORIA I'M
GONNA AYE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO IS AB
TWENTY THREE SEVEN TING.
TING I.
BLOOM.
WE MIGHT.
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE FILE
ITEM NUMBER OF.
FOR I AM IS A DEVICE AS AMENDED
TO ASSEMBLY ON COMMITTEE ON HELP
BLOOM.
WHEN I TING.
TING AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I.
AB TWENTY THREE HUNDRED.
BLOOM.
BUT I TING.
TING AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I
WE NOW RETURN